there are rising concerns today
surrounding an herbal supplement
promoted as a natural alternative to
opioid painkillers the FDA warns it
kratom can be addictive addictive as I
say that word and life-threatening to
kratom is a plant some people use to
treat pain anxiety and depression the
FDA issued a public health advisory
earlier this week warning people about
its possible dangers the agency says
that freedom has similar risks to
opioids and suggested its use could
expand the opioid epidemic Anna Warner's
here with this growing debate over the
supplement kratom Anna good morning good
morning the FDA says there are deadly
risks associated with kratom and the use
of products that contain it a florida
mother who is a registered nurse says
she had never heard of kratom until it
was too late to save her son my son was
my life he was my pal Florida nurse
Linda mantener says her only child
Ian was a happy well liked high school
or who got good grades but that was
before he discovered kratom he began to
be like sneaky and you know sort of
secretive and then his appearance began
to decline mantener says Ian became
addicted to kratom which he was able to
purchase legally after struggling with
his addiction for over two years he
committed suicide he's gone I've got to
learn what normal is and that's hard
kratom grows naturally in Southeast Asia
and is usually sold as a capsule or
powder some people claim it helps them
battle health problems like pain
depression and anxiety others believe it
can serve as an alternative to addictive
opioids but in its new public health
advisory the FDA warns kratom has
similar effects to narcotics like
opioids and carries similar risks of
abuse addiction and in some cases death
the agency says calls to poison control
centers regarding kratom went up tenfold
from 26 in 2010 to 263 in 2015 and there
are reports of 36 deaths associated with
the use of kratom containing products
but some researchers believe it can be
beneficial like University of Florida
medicinal chemistry professor
Christopher mccurdy we thought this had
some potential to investigate as a drug
to treat opioid
diction there's definite therapeutic
potential the FDA encourages proper
research but says so far no marketer has
sought to properly develop a drug and
there are currently no FDA approved
therapeutic uses of kratom Linda
mantener says she feels encouraged that
the FDA is finally stepping up
I loved my child more than anything my
job now is to create awareness and I've
done that five states have already
banned kratom and the FDA says it wants
to keep the drug out of the US entirely
but a group of more than 3 million
kratom users is calling on the FDA to
rescind the warning claiming the science
behind it is weak and some researchers
do say that drug the active ingredients
within kratom might be used to develop a
drug that could help people someday or
eventually so good on the mother to be
speaking out right now in issuing that
warning a lot of parents don't sorry for
her loss and I thank you